et
une actrice aixoise haute en couleurs
une cuisine qui roule des téléphones qui
se recharge au soleil et un chorégraphe
enfermés dans un cube
bienvenue à aix en provence pour ce
nouveau numéro d'itinéraire bis qui n'a
pas rêvé un jour de passer sa retraite à
l'ombre des platanes d'aix en provence
en écoutant l'eau s'écouler du d23
fontaines de la ville ou bien d'y faire
ses études comme les quarante mille
étudiants qui me font déjà dire qu'ici
la vie est douce relève presque du
pléonasme dans cette ville de 150000
habitants qui a vu naître zola et
sézanne une ville qui recèle bien
d'autres secrets
suivez elle est née à aix elle a tourné
avec les plus grands cinéastes français
et italiens mais est toujours resté
fidèle à la capitale historique de la
provence
lellouche truffaut scola ferreri une
centaine de films à son actif un des
visages les plus connus du cinéma
français un franc-parler et un accent
provençal qui la lie à jamais à la ville
qui l'a vu naître
j'ai maintenant rendez vous avec andréa
ferréol
bonjour andré un bonjour merci de nous
accueillir ici alors on est dans un lieu
emblématique la brasserie les deux
garçons en plein coeur du centre-ville
on ne passe pas avec ce sans s'arrêter
ici absolument alors ici c'est un bon
une brasserie qui est classé qui datent
de 1792 qui est une décoration
consulaires et qui est absolument
magnifique parce que regarder ce sont
des petits angelots tout autour la
frisée régler de petits angelots les les
les glaces sont encore avec du mercure
face est vraiment dans son jus c'est
d'une brasserie de l'époque
c'est le lieu de rencontres en tous les
cas c'est l'été à mon époque de tous les
exploits et de toutes les personnalités
bon alors bien sûr c'est anne parait-il
et zola sont venus jouer aux cartes
quand il était jeune et pas encore
brouiller et puis traînée qui habitait
ex enfin toutes les personnalités
aixoise ou non aixoise qui passe avec ce
en provence se doivent de prendre un
verre aux deux garçons alors vous avez
tourné notamment côté de marcelo
mastroianni sous la direction d'être
d'ettore scola
vous avez beaucoup travaillé finalement
de l'autre côté des alpes est ce que
c'est une ville d'aix elle a un petit
côté italien
mais cette vilaine énormissime côté
italien elle est déjà la couleur de la
pierre est comme une tranche de melon
elle est jaune elle est chaleureuse de
la pierre de rognes qui est une petite
une petite ville qui était aux alentours
avec leurs traders
oui donc ces choses est une couleur
chaude quand il fait chaud et que les
cigales chantent parce qu'elle chante
aussi sur le cours mirabeau
tout d'un coup il ya une espèce de
plénitude de bonheur de et puisqu'il
faut dans aig ces marchés ont peu marché
cette ville et n'est pas immense
et donc on peut faire tous à pied on
flâne on s'arrête au produit
de foot elle y ajoute 300 et quelques
fontaines dans l ex c'était pour la
fraîcheur pour les passants et les
places les places est ici vous allez il
faut fouiner il faut c'est un peu comme
à rome vois que vous êtes attaché à
cette ville
alors il ya un personnage qui compte
tout particulièrement dans votre vie et
dans votre ville c'est paul cézanne et
je vous propose qu'on est ensemble faire
un tour dans son atelier absolument
c'est parti
à
on
du haut de ses 1100 mètres elle domine
la ville et invite à la méditation le
promeneur est la montagne
sainte-victoire a été avant tout un
sujet de prédilection pour paul cézanne
le peintre aixois fils de banquier la
dessiner à 60 reprise sous les lumières
changeantes de la provence cézanne
impressionniste sera aussi et surtout
l'un des précurseurs du cubisme
incompris et boudée par les aixois son
époque
il est aujourd'hui célébré
c
gaza
là
mais ce volet 1
web auto
godon blessés
quel endroit impressionnant on est
encore à aix mais un petit peu à
l'extérieur de la ville
à l'époque ce n'était pas une zone
urbanisée aujourd'hui ça l'est un peu
plus et on se trouve dans le dernier
refuge du peintre un oui dans l'atelier
de paul cézanne il s'est fait construire
cet atelier qui dominait la ville et et
qui était en pleine campagne à l'époque
bien évidemment et avant ici il y avait
les oliviers il y avait les figuiers et
puis il ya eu un gel énorme dans les
années 50
tout est mort et donc maintenant la
nature est devenue coquine flamboyante
des gaules est tout à fait dissipées
mais chaleureuse et est belle et sont
vraiment agréables
ah oui oui et puis il ya une espèce de
paix de cet endroit et la paix et vous
allez voir quand on va monter dans son
atelier c'est au delà de la paix andere
en moi j'ai toujours eu la sensation que
cézanne pouvait apparaître allons voir à
la wii dans la télé voir
ça donne
de plus au caire
non
non alors voilà nous entrons dans dans
cet atelier qui a été conçu organisé par
paul cézanne il a fait les plans il en a
choisi la couleur se grille parce
qu'avec ce gris tous les objets peuvent
ressortir et donner leur plein
leur pleine lumière leur plein couleurs
on est dans son dernier atelier 1919
sang il est mort en 1906 andrea on
découvre ici des objets exclusivement
d'époque un rien n'était absolument
alors regardez d'abord son manteau c'est
chapeau ça calme
et puis quand on regarde avec attention
dans dans ses tableaux est ici même
tous ces objets que vous voyez là cet
amour ses vanités la cafetière cette
petite table sont dans les tableaux de
paul cézanne
donc on dirait qu'il va apparaître il ya
son poil on pourrait presque faire du
feu et se dire on va se réchauffer comme
cézanne devait le faire alors
aujourd'hui paul cézanne et célébrer
cela n'a pas toujours été le cas à
l'époque on peut dire ex la bourgeoise
ne s'intéressait pas du tout à ce
peintre qui est finalement mort dans
l'oubli oui il est mort c'est surtout qu
aix en provence la bourgeoisie et
sézanne ça n'allait pas ensemble donc il
était très amis et pendant toute une
époque avec emile zola puis ils se sont
brouillés et cézanne à digérer conquérir
paris avec une pomme bon et est donc à
l'époque aussi il ya eu un directeur du
musée granet et ce monsieur a dit moi
vivant aucun cézanne ne rentrera au
musée et heureusement en 1900 en 2006
nous avons fêté à aix en provence et aix
en provence l'a très bien fêter les 100
ans de la mort de césar avec une immense
et merveilleuse exposition au musée
granet et ça a été
je crois des centaines de milliers de
visiteurs car il ya eu des tableaux qui
sont venues du monde entier et c'était
absolument magnifique et lui a redonné
sa pas besoin qu'on lui a redonné sa
place en lui on l'a fêté on l'a choyé et
c'est vraiment l'enfant d'aix en
provence et c'est vraiment grâce à lui
comme je vous le disais quelque 100
provence et aix en provence
merci andrea et avant de se quitter
c'est la tradition une petite photo un
selphy dans l'atelier de paul cézanne
je vous en avais encore jamais fait
alors je vous propose avec les avait la
grande échelle
alors alors il faut qu'il faut bien
qu'elle rien c'est ça le et attention
sourire
une faculté de droit sont des au xvème
siècle un institut d'études politiques
et des écoles d'ingénieurs
on ne peut pas parler d'aix en provence
sans parler de ses quarante mille
étudiants
ça tombe bien on a passé un bout de
soirée avec eux pour leur demander ce
qu'ils pensaient de leur ville c'est
petit enfants la vie la mentalité
sociale c'est un peu bourgeois quand
même comme ville du comportement a pris
un autre âge dans les jeunes sont déjà
en fête
d'abord les femmes sont très jolies et
en plus d'universités et excellence j'ai
quitté que c'est parce que j'ai loyers
sont trop chers ex déjà ça c'est sûr ces
très bons joueurs et ça coûterait cher
j'étais parisien l'origine j'habite ici
depuis sept ans alors le dit non ils ont
monté à paris n'ont jamais filmé en
jamais maintenant je pense que ça
commence comme ça excellence et qui vend
le ciel les oiseaux des choses un nuage
c'est rare mais on le remarque me voici
à présent au coeur du tout nouveau
quartier d'aix-en-provence sextius
mirabeau à quelques centaines de mètres
seulement de la monumentale fontaine de
la rotonde
ici pas d'hôtels particuliers pas de
vieilles pierres seulement des bâtiments
signés par des architectes contemporains
renommée j'ai maintenant rendez vous
avec angelin prejlocaj un des
chorégraphes français les plus célèbres
installé à aix depuis créé
comment
on
bonjour en juin bonjour merci nous
accueillir dans ce pavillon noir
quel bâtiment ça dénote un peu un dans
le paysage aixois wee cc 1 c'est
vraiment un étendard c'est une oeuvre
une oeuvre radicale qui va avec je crois
là les élans créatifs qui peuvent avoir
lieu ici que ce soit mes créations bien
des chorégraphes qui sont invités alors
c'est un bâtiment qui a été imaginé par
l'architecte du mucem à marseille rudy
ses seins bien avant le mucem à la fois
c'est un bâtiment audacieux et à la fois
il est extrêmement fonctionnel alors il
est constitué par un exosquelette qui
tient les plateformes sur lesquelles ils
laissent passer totalement libéré sans
aucun pilier pour que la danse puisse se
déployer au mieux librement quand on
arrive de l'extérieur et qu'on voit ce
cube de 3000 m² fait de béton et de
verre
on peut dire que c'est un peu dur pour
célébrer la danse oui mais vous savez là
dedans sont souvent attribués à la danse
des vertus de grâce de beauté et
effectivement c'est vrai mais si on par
exemple si on fait référence et à la
peinture
on a souvent ça aussi c'est à dire
l'idée que la peinture doit être belle
gracieuse mais la peinture aussi reflète
la violence du monde et et pas seulement
de beauté diaphane comme ça et la danse
aussi à ce côté aussi très rugueux je
trouve que il ce bâtiment a une beauté
je trouve qu'il n'est donc pas du tout
par rapport à l'art chorégraphique
mais vous nous fait visiter oui
m
je suis en juin montrent assez marches
en béton où il ya des noms d'inscrits
voilà en fait j'ai souhaité mettre sur
chaque marche du bâtiment les noms des
danseurs qui ont participé à l'histoire
et à l' aventure du ballet et donc
chaque danseur à apporter à l'édifice sa
pierre et a permis la contrée joli
symbole et la scène de cette salle de
spectacles dans les antres du pavillon
noir
oui dans les entrailles du pavillon noir
on trouve cette salle de spectacle
magnifique qui est une des indes et des
éléments forts de ce bâtiment puisque
c'est un des seuls centre chorégraphique
national qui a sa propre salle de
spectacle alors vous êtes alex
maintenant quel lien vous avez avec les
ex soir avec ses habitants j'ai un lien
très fort parce que d'abord je vis et je
travaille à aix depuis 20 ans quasiment
et puis j'ai créé une cellule qui
s'appelle le guide
c'est un petit geek qui veut dire qui
est le groupe urbain d'intervention
danser et son rôle ses six danseurs un
peu qu'ils qui vont dans les halls et
les hôpitaux les écoles les lycées les
places de village a porté la danse
évidemment dans des endroits où elle ne
va pas forcément je partis du principe
que c'était souvent les les gens qui
venaient vers la danse en allant dans
les théâtres et rarement la danse qui va
vers les gens et donc j'ai créé ce
groupe et ça a créé un lien très fort
avec
la ville et la région et ça ça n'a fait
qu'agrandir là le public de la danse
vous parlez dans mener la danse dans la
ville je sais pas si vous le savez mais
juste à côté d'ici dans un hôpital
psychiatrique qui utilisent la culture
bis of exactement pour accompagner les
malades on a été à leur rencontre
on y va tous un hôpital comme lieu de
création
preuve que la culture peut servir à
autre chose qu'être ému ou surpris
depuis 30 ans grâce à une femme
ce pavillon de l'hôpital psychiatrique
mon père un accueil des artistes et
associe les passions à la création de ce
qui en fait sa particularité c'est la
double adresse le fait de s'adresser
aussi bien les personnes hospitalisées
que non hospitalisés l'idée de faire
rentrer à l'intérieur de l'hôpital des
gens de la cité
et puis d'être aussi on est un lieu qui
s'intitule d'art contemporain c'est à
dire de proposer à des artistes
d'utiliser l'espace pour leur démarche
de création
le pavillon 3 bis f c'est son nom est un
projet sans équivalent en france un
service
parmi les autres services de soins
l'hôpital et s'il n'est pas question de
soigner par là ce lieu qui est aussi un
lieu d'exposition nous invite à changer
notre regard sur la folie
quatre maintenant sur le château de
galice à quelques kilomètres du
centre-ville mais je n'ai pas rendez
vous avec les descendant d'une grande
famille aixoise
mais avec un chercheur et un inventeur
qui ont lancé il y a 6 ans du verre
photovoltaïques souples et transparents
qui pourrait bien révolutionner notre
quotidien
donc bonjour nous sommes ici au château
de galice à quelques kilomètres du
centre ville d'aix pas très loin vous
avez vos laboratoires la société sun
partners où vous fabriquer du verre
photovoltaïque un peu spécial oui en
effet nous fabriquons du verre
photovoltaïque transparent donc il peut
s'appliquer sur n'importe quelle surface
pour apporter de l'énergie à des
applications qui en ont besoin
déjà c'est une première mondiale aucune
société n'a réussi aujourd'hui à l'ailé
transparence au dessus de 50% ça donne
ça c'est ça cette petite vitre je vous
laisse là prendre parce que c'est très
fragile
oui en effet là c'est complètement
transparent voit rien il ya des cellules
photovoltaïques ici exactement donc ça
c'est une cellule photovoltaïque donc un
panneau solaire transparent et qui
lorsqu'on met à la lumière et bien
permet de convertir la lumière en
électricité donc de produire de
l'énergie aie qui va pouvoir se poser
notamment sur quoi un téléphone portable
exactement donc on va pouvoir le poser
sur un écran de téléphone portable comme
celui ci vous voyez qu'on voit
parfaitement l'écran il n'y a pas
d'impact visuel du tout sûr sur l'écran
et donc exposé à la lumière là l'énergie
est transformée en énergie électrique
qui rechargent la batterie du téléphone
avec une minute au soleil et bien on
peut avoir une minute
d'usagé par exemple pour écouter de la
musique unis et au soleil c'est une idée
de batterie c'est une minute d'usagé de
musique d'accord où ça va être dix
minutes au soleil vous allez pouvoir
avoir un appel de deux minutes
vous êtes en train de dire que vous avez
dans vos mains un téléphone qui se
déchargera plus jamais alors il se
déchargera quand même mais c'est en fait
c'est un complément énergétique qui
permet de sécuriser certaines appliquée
alors ce téléphone vous l'avez fait avec
le géant chinois alcatel c'est un
prototype
là vous en avez un autre qui est déjà
commercialisé mais c'est un téléphone de
luxe y coûte 8000 euros ça veut dire que
le téléphone est de cellules
photovoltaïques on leur a pas encore
dans notre poche dès demain oui parce
que l'on nous nous avons ici à aix en
provence une ligne de pré-production
fait des petites séries l'avantagent
d'un téléphone de luxe et qu'il est
vendu en petite série et donc c'est ce
qu'on a fait avec avec tiger se
téléphonent serbie joue ça voilà c'est
un bijou en parallèle en effet le but
c'est de lancer des produits en masse
volume avec alcatel mais aussi demain
avec d'autres marques
alors on a l'image d'aix comme une ville
de culture ici vous développez vos
laboratoires vos recherches
qu'est-ce que vous êtes venu trouver ici
avec son produit alors la raison pour
laquelle on est arrivé ici c'est que via
un écosystème de la microélectronique
il ya de grosses entreprises du cac 40
gemalto stmicroelectronics puis des
entreprises de l'environnement de la
micro et roddick comme atmel est donc le
fait de pouvoir s'installer ici nous
avait aussi à recruter des équipes dans
des équipes de chercheurs
on trouve ici aussi le cea qui est qu'on
va pas très loin d'aix en provence et
les équipes du cea nous ont aidés dans
plusieurs projets pour développer
l'entreprise
vous êtes installé finalement quelque
part dans la seine vallées d'ax
voilà c'est un peu ça c'est une petite
silicon valley provençal ludovic vous
avez commencé à quelques kilomètres
d'ici dans un technopole révolutionnaire
qui donne notamment sa chance à des
petites entreprises
ok me voici dans un paysage provençal
sous les pins pour un peu on pourrait
croiser les démarches en goguette ou des
peintres amateurs et bien pas du tout
nous sommes au coeur d'un site dédié à
l'environnement un parc d'entreprises
unique en europe
bonjour frédéric faure quelle drôle
d'endroit pour des entreprises ici il ya
80 ans étaient des malades un qui est
allé effectivement on était sur un
ancien sanatorium qui appartenait au
conseil général des bouches du rhône où
on venait en fait quelque part respirait
le bonheur de la campagne pour les
maladies pulmonaires quand on savait pas
dé soigner et c'est devenu un parc
d'entreprises alors aujourd'hui il y à
1500 emplois exact 200 entreprises qui
sont dédiés à l'environnement milieu de
ce paysage provençal et vous avez été
les premiers à travailler sur
l'environnement
effectivement quand l'opération a été
lancée on peut dire en 1995 ça a été
l'année de la première implantation d'un
grand laboratoire de recherche qui
s'appelle le centre européen de
recherche et d'enseignement sur les jo
sciences de l'environnement et petit à
petit autour de ce laboratoire de
recherche des start up des pépinières
d'entreprises et d'autres laboratoires
de recherche sont venues s'implanter sur
une thématique qui à l'époque n'était
pas forcément une thématique que l'on
pouvait penser être une thématique à
vocation économique et à l'époque on
pensait que l'écologie était juste un
sujet de préservation de l'environnement
et on se doutait peut-être pas que
derrière ça il ya des trucs des filières
autour des énergies renouvelables autour
de la gestion des risques naturels
dépollution des déchets et dépollution
de sols
tout ça ça représente beaucoup d'emplois
et beaucoup de d'innovation vous nous
fait visiter pour voir un peu ce que ça
donne et quelle entreprise
allons-y on y va alors c'est un bâtiment
exceptionnel en pleine nature
il ya les pins de cette nature très
provençal on va trouver quoi comme comme
entreprise dédiée à l'environnement des
choses très différentes
alors effectivement des choses très
différentes autant d entreprises qui
travaillent dans le domaine des énergies
renouvelables comme notamment la société
nénuphars qui va développer des
éoliennes que l'on va mettre dans les
mers en offshore on a des entreprises
qui vont travailler sur la création de
capteurs qu'on va mettre dans les
voitures qui vont analyser les sens et
permettent de réduire la consommation de
sa voiture à la production de co2 ce
sont des start up qui sont allés en bas
d'hier entre une et 30 personnes sur le
sur le site est l'objet même du
technopole c'est de comprendre que
ensemble face à des grands groupes
on est plus fort c'est ce qu'on vous
souhaite frédéric merci de nous avoir
accueillis ici on va poursuivre notre
visite à travers
en provence merci frédéric à bientôt
enfin vous connaissez le camion à pizza
la baraque à frites venu tout droit des
états unis le phénomène qui est
certes pas fabriqué dans un camion
connaît depuis quelques années un succès
bien français pas toujours simple pour
eux de trouver un lieu où s'installer à
aix christophe et grégory laurent
trouver une solution avec un site dédié
ah les dernières étapes de la découverte
d'aix en provence un camion cinq
spécialités un parking qui de marié de
ses crêpes bretonnes de coralie et de
ses hamburgers version originale de issa
et tim voulez il ya ça de patrice est un
café bien serré de 210 et ses bagages
chez maison sera désigné par julie comme
meilleure cuisine en lente
réponse après dégustation bonjour samedi
vous êtes en plein préparatif qu'est ce
qu'on va manger ce midi dans votre outre
' alors ce midi c'est salade de
tagliatelles saumon fumé poêlée de
légumes champignons courgettes alors le
foutraque c'est devenu votre quotidien
mais c'est une seconde vie exactement
oui à la base je suis dans la
communication l'événementiel voilà et
c'est vrai que j'ai eu envie c'est
peut-être bête ce que je vais vous dire
mais d'évasion c'est à dire que me
retrouver tous les jours
derrière un bureau quelque chose de mon
automne dont j'avais envie de rencontrer
du monde j'adore rencontrer les gens
donc forcément le foot rucks et l
alternative idéale et ça vous a coûté
combien l'investissement pour ce projet
alors moi mon camion m'a coûté 46 mille
euros exactement
j'ai pris le temps d'où le projet gelé
commencé il ya un peu plus d'un an et
j'ai ouvert il ya quatre mois voilà j'ai
vraiment pris le temps de tout calcul
est de savoir combien ça allait me
coûter qui pouvaient m'accueillir parce
que outre que c'est ça c'est fou je peux
me placer alors on peut se dire que les
cuisiner dans un camion s'est pas
forcément l'idéal il ya pas beaucoup de
place c'est ce qu'on peut vraiment
parler de cuisine maison
oui on peut parler de cuisine maison
parce que le camion est équipé de
communes cuisine je pense que vous
regardez si comme une cuisine de
professionnels tous les produits qu'on a
ici devant dos et des produits frais
naturels n'y a rien de surgelés non non
non ça c'est d'ailleurs je pense que
nous devons garder dans le camion je
n'ai pas de congélateur
d'accord c'est cette chose voilà c'est
quelque chose d'important pour moi je ne
veux surtout pas de surgelés et surtout
qu'on est dans le sud donc le produit le
produit frais le produit des petits
producteurs des choses comme ça c'est
parce qu'il manque ici et c'est
important
c'est important de
retrouvez ça dans les dents les
assiettes même si on est dans un camion
pourrait se dire non c'est peut-être de
la mal bouffe tout simplement alors que
pas du tout il y a deux personnes qui
vous ont trouvé une solution pour
installer les camions on va aller les
rencontrer tout de suite moi je vous
laisse travailler parce que je crois que
les premiers clients voire et la wii là
il est l'heure pour moi d'attaquer
merci 5
il était organisé
bonjour christophe au jour julie alors
c'est l'heure du déjeuner nous voici à
table et on est sur une sorte de parking
de food trucks et qu'est ce que vous
proposez ici alors on offre du choix de
la diversité et de la convivialité pour
les clients voilà plusieurs camions
restaurant tous les jours viennent
proposer leurs préparations
voilà du fait maison du fait camion que
des produits frais on offre du choix la
convivialité pour les clients ils ont en
général qu'une heure pour déjeuner et
voilà ce qu'ont ce qu'on essaye de leur
offrir c'est de faire de faire une vraie
coupure de venir faire il n'y a ni
déconnecte et il retourne audureau après
heureux d'où est ce qu'elle vous est
venue cette idée
c'est parti tout simplement de l'idée de
faire faire notre propre camion et
devant le problème d'emplacement les
mairies ne donne pas d'emplacement
pas de loi vide juridique on s'est
retrouvé à chercher notre propre
remplacement tout simple parce que quand
on est un fou de toi qu'on peut pas se
garer n'importe où comme ça comme lady
au camion à pizza qu'on connaît non et
vous quand vous leur proposez ici sur un
espace privé que vous louez un
emplacement que vous leur loyer
également ça exactement
voilà le fonctionnement est simple on a
un vrai bail commercial et derrière on
fait de la sous location
ces camions ils sont soumis aux mêmes
obligations que les restaurants
traditionnels en termes de droits en
termes d'hygiène
on a la même réglementation les règles
sont les mêmes pour la restauration
qu'elle soit mobile au fixe
et en plus nous on est
exigeant avec eux on leur demande de
signer une charte d'engagement de
qualité et on a les mêmes règles
d'hygiène
voilà et de produits on a la même
traçabilité on a la même réglementation
on n'est plus dans la concurrence
déloyale merci beaucoup christopher moi
je pense que maintenant on va nous
coûter ce bagage
allez bon appétit et après on se fait
une petite photo c'est la tradition dans
l'émission alors on rassemble tout le
monde pour la photo et quel meilleur
track sur des allées sur définitivement
les garçons derrière
là
si vous souhaitez poursuivre la balade à
la découverte de cette ville je vous
propose trois ouvrages le guide secret
d'aix-en-provence
un guide insolite qui vous emmène à la
découverte des lieux les plus
improbables de cette ville ce livre
intitulé pavillon noir sur la génèse du
projet avec une série d'entretiens
croisés entre l'architecte rudy
ricciotti et du chorégraphe angelin
prejlocaj et enfin ce dernier ouvrage
nos voix d'espérance d'olivier nerfs aux
éditions des liens qui libèrent un livre
mais également un souffle d'optimisme et
d' enthousiasme porté par dix
personnalités de pierre rabhi à nicolas
nuit
on ne pouvait pas terminer cette
émission sans vous proposer un dernier
numéro de cirque celui des petites
étoiles du siam
le centre international des arts en
mouvement qui a ouvert il ya un an juste
à côté d'ici à très bientôt pour une
nouvelle balade dans une france
inattendu on a tout sous l'air de cani
même anton des zones érogènes au moins
400 millions d'euros pour fif et l'uriné
ya des jours au malabar a d'autres où
l'on a mal à l'âme et qu'on sache pas
balayer le corps est plus cher au final
et notre camp c'est maxime à la plupart
des chèques pétales ont passé tous nos
voisins aussi que des chèques au mental
alors on vit on voit cette politique
sera est un tapin de la finance à la
sorte de l'île humains aujourd'hui l'un
d'eux me suis pas fait tourner en
serrant des mains l'activité qu'aussitôt
calado mais tu crèves là-bas agrippé au
rex sipa du vont manger le lendemain la
capitulation soupe à l'info m'adresse
thomas sans permis qui datent de racine
au chocolat justement avoir dû passer
par le bistouri manière la plus honnête
de placebo la canicule en douceur monte
il abolit leurs élèves ne mettrait pas
en place